To wrap up this lesson,
we want to make sure we drive
home these two main points.
It is incredibly important that
you're always doing experiments and
iterating on your marketing decisions.
Don't make assumptions,
base your decisions on your research.
And don't waste time on planning
the best strategy on the first go,
just get started.
You can iterate on your plan as you go.
It's more important to measure and
improve your performance than it is to
get the absolute perfect plan down.
>> Also, find the right balance
between your qualitative insights and
your quantitative data that you
receive through your experiments and
user testing.
You want to learn what's happening with
your marketing message through your data
and why it's happening
through your user testing.
This way you're going to be able to make
more informed decisions in the future.
>> And hopefully, you are in
the mindset of building, measuring and
learning from marketing
experiments on an online basis.
>> Now we really want to congratulate
you on completing this course and
we wish you the best of luck
in your future endeavors.
Come back and share [INAUDIBLE]
with us when you have them, bye.